- I'm James Briscione, director
of culinary research here
at the Institute of Culinary Education.
Today, we're going to make
your Big Mac meal fancy.
So we're going to start
things off here with a little
French fry mousse.
We took our large French fries,
blended them with a
little bit of hot milk,
which makes this beautiful,
creamy, potato puree,
and we're going to load that into
the whipping canister here.
That's going to create a
beautiful, silky, potato mousse.
Alright, so that's potato mousse.
Now, ketchup caviar.
I love ketchup in my burger.
Ketchup can look a whole lot better.
We're going to start here with
just a bit of water and agar.
We're going to take that
and whisk it into the water.
The reason we like agar instead of gelatin
is that because it will stay
gelled at warm temperatures,
where gelatin is going to
dissolve really quickly.
So the agar and water
mixture has come to a boil.
Now we just turn that down
and add our ketchup.
Let that ketchup and agar cook
together for just a moment.
So agar and ketchup mixture
in the squeeze bottle.
This is where things get fun.
We've got a bath of cold oil.
So this is oil that's been in the freezer
and is now sitting over ice,
so it's super, super cold.
So we take our hot ketchup-agar mixture,
and we're going to drop
it into ice cold oil.
So if we add it drop by drop,
we're going to get perfect
little pearls of ketchup.
Really cool little trick,
you can do this with any kind of liquid,
fruit juices, and really
anything you want.
Now we just scoop these guys up
and drop them into a
little water to rinse,
there it is, ketchup caviar.
I think we're ready to plate.
So here we go.
We got our Big Mac,
went ahead and grabbed a plate
of just some extra, kind
of typical burger toppings,
pickles, lettuce, tomato, onion.
We got our mustard and ketchup.
We're ready to go.
We're actually going to start here
with a little bit of ketchup
and a little bit of mustard.
You know you need that on your burger
right next to each other.
And then, I'm going to
take a paintbrush and just
run that right through.
Nice little base there.
We've got our
French fry mousse.
Just going to kinda drop
a little bit of that
down around the plate.
That's going to just
kinda set up the frame
for our burger.
Now, our Big Mac,
take this bad boy apart.
I've got one patty with the cheese
and then another patty.
So we're going to take those two guys,
slice those and just kinda frame them up,
and they're going to rest right here
between that French fry mousse.
And now we're starting
to set up a little bit of
framing and a little
movement on the plate.
Bun is going to give us
some nice little textures.
I'm going to take that bun,
actually tear it into pieces,
and just drop it right around here.
So now we're starting to
kinda fill out this plate.
We're getting a good look.
Tuck that right around there.
Then our little garnishes here.
So we've got our pickles
and just drop some nice
pickles right in there,
love pickles so we're
going with lots of these,
little bit of onion,
tuck those right in,
love these little rings right here.
Now a bit of our tomato,
just cut it up into some small pieces,
get some different shapes happening,
so they tuck right in.
And then finish it all with
some nice fresh lettuce here,
get a nice little shape on that,
just like this.
Drop three of those around there.
Looking really good.
So our burger's plated
and then we finish it off
with my favorite piece,
that ketchup caviar.
We just grab a little
bit of our caviar there,
and now we're going to
drop it right in there.
And with ketchup caviar, there it is,
the Big Mac meal transformed.